Let's go next to our caller from the 7 0 4
area code who's calling today from 7 0 4.
Hey, David is me.
Yeah, that's you.
Who's this?
My name is Dawn from Charlotte.
Hey, Jordan, what's up?
Just want to tell you, I'm a huge fan.
I watch him all the time.
Thank you.
I just had a I just had a quick question about
mirror voting, about sorry.
Male or male in voting.
Yes.
Merit, merit, boating, voting.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes.
God, yes.
So I was just thinking, since, you know, we
got Trump, of course, that got me thinking
that really I don't think that voting is so
much of a right as it is a privilege.
So in that I would say I would just like to
ask you what the thoughts of sort of a maybe
like something like a citizenship test, but
not the citizenship test.
But something just so that you're knowledgeable
and that you're informed about who and what
you are voting for.
Yeah, whether that be lyssa quote.
Right.
I've taken versions of this question dozens
of times over the years.
And I get the instinct.
I've taken it.
Also, in terms of parenting, like, wouldn't
we be way better off if you had to pass some
tests to be a parent?
And wouldn't we be way better off if you had
to pass some basic test in order to vote?
I understand why.
Why that instinct comes up.
I really do.
But it just can't be done.
It can't be done because you first of all,
I don't believe that it would be constitutional.
Number one, that that because even though
you consider voting a privilege, it is a right.
It is a right that people have.
And it can only be removed under very narrow
circumstances, most most of which I actually
disagree with.
So in practice, anything like that, any kind
of voting test or parenting test, as others
have suggested, it would end up disproportionately
impacting poor people where part of the problem
is they're already lacking access to education.
So I it it would have disastrous unintended
or intended depending on who you are, consequences.
And I get the instinct.
I don't think you're coming for it from a
bad place.
Like how did sixty three million people get
bamboozled into voting for Donald Trump?
I get it.
But it would be very problematic in its application.
Yeah, totally agree.
And I think that's why we would need to fix
other problems, such as health care, education,
right, college tuition, etc..
It's tough to write like it sounds easier
to just put in place a voting test rather
than to deal with those issues.
But but you're you're agreeing that those
are the issues that really we got to deal
with.
Yes, of course.
Thank you for your insight.
Appreciate it.
Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.